SCP-096 Vs SCP-204.
They say that SCP-096 always catches its prey,
but could the strength of The Protector finally
stop it at the door?
Let’s find out.
SCP-096 is a relentless and almost indestructible
killing machine that doesn’t even leave
traces of its victims left.
Nothing seems to be able to even slow it down.
SCP-204 is a cloud of deadly, self-replicating
nanites that recharge by feeding on living
flesh, are able to condense into a powerful
physical form, and will do anything to protect
the child they are assigned to.
However, we think 096 would still narrowly
win this one.
Unlike 096, 204’s condensed form is vulnerable
to conventional damage - which 096 can dish
out in spades - and 096 would likely regenerate
flesh faster than 204 could reliably eat it.
The Protector’s host child may sadly be
doomed on this one…